all right Billy yes Billy uh where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
I'm originally from Bogota South America
Colombia
tell me about your family
My real father was an alcoholic and my
mom's probably the most incredible human
being I ever met in my life
stands at 4 11 and had a second grade
education and raised four kids without
you know with the second grade education
it's pretty tough she's
um she's the reason I am who I am you
know the champion I became and the
gentleman The Classy man that I am I
consider myself honored to have her as a
mother she
so I do an emotional
she passed away this month uh December
4th I'm sorry now she lived her life she
would she died at the age of 90. how
would you describe your childhood in
general
um well let's get back to the the you
know growing up part my mom remarried
the lieutenant commander in the United
States Navy
his name was John winland my original
name is guerobo corridor
my mother's maiden name is corridor and
he was a very very good man very strong
disciplined man
and he put me on a farm you know in
Indiana but you know I don't know if you
let me go to that part yet that's the
growing up part
I was only I probably owned this tall
I was five five years old maybe four and
a half
and um
it was way back in the woods where you
have an outhouse and you have a you know
limited things that modern man had put
it this way if you've got snake bit you
were done
because nearest hospital was probably
two two hours by helicopter and uh
you're not gonna make it
so it uh that's where I learned to ride
a horse my job being the rent of 15 boys
was to get the horses in the morning and
uh I looked at my uncle and said how am
I going to do that yeah he literally
gave me a stick with a carrot and then I
walked out there and the main one would
see the carrot and he'd start walking
and they I'm just tall those horses were
huge you know but um that's uh the thing
that I loved the most about my childhood
was being on that farm because I was a
man at six
easy because you there's so much wild
and it's a jungle you know literally uh
and uh
one day we were um
on the horse first time we've been on a
horse as a quarter horse named champ
and I didn't know his ad you know his
habits and things but uh they go okay
and you know no saddle bareback just a
rope around his nose which we call you
know of course facing a bit
and a bridle but uh he goes okay let's
go back home and we're at the bottom of
this road was probably a quarter mile
easy at the end was the house
and I turned around and as soon as champ
turned he just took off and I didn't
know that he would stop at the top and I
looked down I'd never been so scared in
my life those legs started just
disappearing as if they went faster and
faster you couldn't see him anymore like
you know it was just one whole motion
I jumped off I was scared it was a big
ditch right next to it to the road that
had grass about this tall so I knew I'd
be okay I've been walking through I
jumped off and went in there
my
friend Danny he was the oldest guy
he said what the hell are you doing
and he was put me on a Crazy Horse for
her he was no he's going to stop at the
top of the hill I go yeah now you tell
me
every day every day after that
I waited for them to turn theirs around
because I knew I would blow them away as
soon as I turned him around man he was
rolling and I didn't have a saddle you
know just that's where I learned it you
have to be a jockey you have to
you got to have the Rhythm the flow
you you can't be bouncing around and
moving up on his back because you can
throw him off stride and he's not going
to be confident with you there
when you Shoemaker told me there's
there's jockeys and there's race Riders
I'm blessed to be able to say I Was a
Race writer you um
lecture maker and all the great
you're there but you're not there
the horse has no idea you're up there as
far as the horse knows that you're there
but as far as the uh load that he's got
on his back
it's like it's part of him that's the
best way to explain it you're part of
that horse you're in Rhythm every stride
every muscle is all you just you're not
moving you're flowing
it's that's when that's when a good
horse
runs his best race
you know when he's comfortable that you
are not even there you just let them
know when it's time to get get down you
know and put them in position
but um
the other one's uh
I from there I grew up in Glendale
I've been here since I was uh
but it's it's eight seven eight years
old
my mom could put us in a car and drove
us across you know the United States in
a beautiful car
and uh first thing I did was I'm a
I'm a go-getter you know I don't wait
for something to come to me
and uh
I've I knew my mom needed help
you know with you know taking care of
his feedness and stuff
we uh got a place down there in the near
Watts
I think it was 28th Street
and uh I might looking for a job
eight years old
most kids are at home you know the
parents that
I I you know I'm
I gotta help
so I gotta be honest with you I don't
remember how I got the job either it was
with the selling the herald examiner
um between cars when they would stop at
the light
and uh I'll do that I'd walk between the
cars they didn't know anybody was there
so I'd have to pick the paper up and
walk with it like this so they could see
somebody carrying a newspaper
people would say hello Examiner and then
I remember some guy came
put up a knife up to my back
and I said are you serious
you're gonna kill me for a dollar in
dimes
and also and I hear a gun click because
I when I was growing up on that farm I
you know we I learned how to shoot
actually pretty good you know
better than every average person
and um I hear a click and I go man
that's a that's a pistol now I got
another guy or unless he's got a pistol
and I hear a deep voice go put that
knife down I won't use any of the words
he you know he used but and you tell
everybody Big John's got his back I said
wow who is Big John I haven't turned
around yet so I turned around and I go
wow now I know why they call you Big
John huge huge man and he goes don't
worry son I got you everybody knows not
nobody's gonna mess with you but uh and
I gave him a paper every day free but uh
I I think I was only out there maybe I
don't know probably three weeks because
uh my mom you know she came one day and
I was pouring rainbow I was still
selling that paper
I think that's why I did good in the
rain when I was when I was riding horses
jockey really don't bother me it's just
water and uh
she goes Come On Son get in and uh that
was the end of my selling the head
examiner days
from there I went to a school called
named holy family I got fortunate enough
to go to a you know well a good
education well-educated School
and uh we were poor so
gentleman by the name of John Wagner was
a big time lawyer
he helped my mom and us you know very
very very good man
his kids were um swimmers you know they
had big pool and everything
and uh so I went to Holy Family I was an
altar boy
from uh fourth grade I got there till
eighth grade
I do mass and I think that's where God
blessed me because uh I do churches mass
at 5 30 in the morning and I do funerals
and weddings and so I didn't really have
that much of a normal childhood of
playing and stuff me I always wanted to
work you know that was I wasn't getting
paid for doing that but um
I I you know I sacrificed my childhood a
little bit that's the only way that's
the only way I can explain how God
blessed me so much
as far as being an athlete I'm a
world-class athlete that's I'm 5'3
and um
from uh there I went to uh Glendale High
but when I was in my family I worked uh
I wanted to see like I got to have a job
I got to be helping my mom
and uh there's a Mercury right there at
the corner of uh
Lomita and um
Glendale Avenue Willis Market I went in
there every day when I was fourth grade
asked him hey can I can I do something I
need work you know
the guy finally got he got his name was
George masako great man good man
and uh he said son you know Italian real
straight down uh hardcore Italian
and they said you watch this parking lot
okay son and there was a boy Nelly down
the street and he said he says anybody
Parks here doesn't go in that store you
tell them that they have to move their
cars for Market parking only
and I said then what you know I'm only
the store he's gonna laugh at me he goes
no he won't you come get me oh he was he
was a big man but I don't make six two
real strong he could take a phone book
literally
and rip it in half
that blew me away that's crazy anybody
ever tried that it's that's crazy and uh
so it happened one day and I told him
wait right here I'll be right back I
really got George you looked at him goes
hey you know in Italian told me you know
move the car okay I never had I never
worried about having somebody move the
car again
from there and I went to Glendale High
School
uh and so um I
still works at the market and I had
another job up the street at a place
called Foster Freeze
I was it is as a young kid I always had
at least 300 bucks in my pocket
you know it felt comfortable you know
pressing up with my mom
and uh
I wanted to play uh I know it sounds
crazy but I wanted to play a sport
because when I first came from Indiana I
didn't know what football was we didn't
have no TV out there in the woods you
know that's the jungle
and uh real jungle if I had a man tell
me when I was in Watts son you're in the
jungle I go no this is not a jungle
these are people
I came from a jungle that's a jungle
bears and mountain lions and snakes you
know yeah watch yourself
but uh so
um I mean Glendale and I wanted to play
uh I want to play sporting football team
wanted me to play a punt return come on
upon return those guys are two members
250 300 pounds
they hit me or following me this game
over for me I'm not going to do that
that's insanity and I've admire football
players those those athletes are they're
something else they're really something
else man they hit each other like
they're like like it's nothing you know
it's like you're playing a little video
game boom boom now they get up and walk
away I don't think I would have gotten
up after the first point return the
honest with you and so
I I decided to play basketball because I
was always dribbling the ball and
playing at a place called Maple Park
and uh you know being smaller you know I
knew I had to really you know really put
out and you know be fast be quick and
be ahead of the guy that I'm gardening
you know keep them from getting near
that rim
so
Varsity you know that's what you want to
dream of
uh went out for that and it was 250 guys
I think went out for it
but I got lucky I made it you know that
I I don't say that that's not a good
word I worked hard I worked hard to get
there every day that ball was in my hand
and I was always at Maple Park every
night after work playing or on weekends
and you know these guys they'd have some
really really good Ballers there boys
could ball and so you know you learn to
play better by playing against the best
you know
so I was I played uh at Glendale High
Varsity which was you know I was I was
honored for that and I played against uh
Michael Cooper Coupe he was he was as
good in high school as he was in Pros
when he'd come guard me because he went
to Pasadena I went to Glendale I'd say
come on Coop you know he'd smile and say
I'll let you shoot it and I kept
thinking man his arm spam was just like
he met he immense but I'd have to go
like way out there to get around that
arm
and uh I had a good time doing that and
uh I knew I wasn't good enough to play
college ball you know you you have to be
realistic about things in life
you know you can set a goal but you know
be realistic about your talent and you
know you work hard you could do it then
you know go get it you know my my
philosophy in life has always been um
God number one that's just me though
and uh then the four D's I caught I
called the G and the four D's God then
there's discipline desire dedication
and uh determination
you wake up every day I I lived it
and look at that wall I'd put God and
all the four D's and you keep that the
whole day
you cannot fail it's impossible the only
one that could beat you is yourself and
that wasn't going to happen no I don't I
don't I don't shoot myself in the foot
and uh that's how I got to play ball so
when I got to high school
now I started thinking oh what am I
gonna do
you know I couldn't play couldn't play
pro ball
and so uh
I was kicking it with my my girlfriend
at the time
Loretta Miller her dad her brother and I
were um
um really good friends we met in grade
school remember I was telling the story
about I didn't know what football was
we wanted to you know playground and the
saint Davis played football come on we
need one more
I was embarrassed to say I don't know
what football is what do I do he says
just going to touch that guy just touch
him that's all the guy with the ball oh
I can do that that's easy
so I pushed the link out of the way
he touched him and he stood through the
ball and
hey I touched him and he threw a TD
and he looked at me George Miller this
great athlete really good athlete and he
goes no you didn't I gotta tell you what
next time I touch it you're gonna know I
touched you and he was taller than me
Well everybody's taller than me he was
about five nine five eleven so I came in
next time and I said boom drilled him
right there dropped him
and you know a little guy but hey you
know I'm a little crazy sometimes and I
looked down at him did I get you that
time
he goes you got me
I was the first one he ever picked after
that he didn't want to get hit so
um
I went I was telling you about my uh
girlfriend George or dad was George
Miller
we called him Yogi because he looked
like a little teddy bear
and uh
he uh was a fun guy we had kick it over
his house you know on on weekends with
my girlfriend
and um
he said hey he called me bolognaires
Jackson because I I got my mom's ears I
have some big ears you think but um
he goes come on with one of the Races
they go I didn't I I was
I don't want the horse faces I mean I've
seen him on TV but I didn't know they
were in my backyard I didn't know that
they rode right there but see I wasn't
even interested in that though because
it didn't click yet you know my past on
the farm and and horse racing I wish it
would have clicked when I was 16 because
that's when you can start uh now I'm 18
and so
we went there and I walked in there and
I I walked up literally to the rail at
Santa Anita and I said what is this here
and I went back talked to my
father-in-law I mean he was after yeah
that no I hadn't gotten married yet but
he would he would become my father
and I said Yogi excuse me
do they get paid to do this because I
needed to make money
you know I like to have money in my
pocket I like to help my mom
he goes
Billy those are they're millionaires
they go really
I can do that Yogi he goes
Billy those are those are Hall of Fame
jockey's best in the world
and then he says
no more beer for bolognaires Jackson
here you know you'd like to have a beard
once in a while
and um
I went back up to the rail
I mean ah this this Stadium that's what
you know I called it because it's it's a
it's like when you go to the Forum it's
a basketball court but with no walls or
anything it's it's like an imaginary
huge Dome over the the track to me
that's where I looked at it because I
was just playing in gyms you know and I
didn't know how else to explain it to
myself
because these are professional athletes
these in Santa Anita's
to anybody you mentioned Anita that's
top of the world that's that's your
that's your uh
number one class right there you know
don't get me wrong New York is you know
same thing you know Belmont and you know
aqueduct in those places you know like
you get great jockeys they're a hall of
famers Cordero and you know Pat day and
you know Bailey I mean you can go on and
on the last kids you know
but I was on the south I mean the West
Coast here and I was uh
I was with I called creme de La Creme
listen Shoemaker defeating Kai Chris
McCarron Toro Valenzuela
de la hoosi
mccarg it goes the list goes on and on
on and on
I was like it's wow this is deep
but only when I knew of at the time
was the Shoemaker you know name-wise
that I recognized and uh in the feet
pink eye
two of the greatest Jokers ever
they were born they'll go down in
history forever for that
should make your head this finesse and
the hands
they'd only come once in a lifetime
maybe never ever again and the feet
wow
how can you describe the philippinekai
I I described him as um
like uh
a man chiseled literally chiseled out of
granite because he was just he was he
was I called him a specimen he was a
specimen of a man you know just every
every muscle would show and it was
perfect and when he would walk by you to
go to take a shower at the end of the
day
I kid you not
you feel the aura of a champion walking
through you just you get chills a little
bit wow
I'm writing against that guy
but it gets you motivated get you pumped
up it gets you on your A-game you know
because yeah you're you're competing
with that
you know
let's rock let's do this let's get this
on you know
this is after I you know got where I was
going
but um
from there
I'm like this is this is the God's truth
and anybody that hears this story if you
don't believe me it's okay because I
know it happened
and that's all that matters and God
knows
I was up at the rail that day
and they came out of the gate I'll never
forget it Harry uh Harry Hansen
and there they go
and he you know he had that deep voice
and I and I would this was listening to
him I didn't know who Harry Hansen was
but I remember and he I heard him say
they're into the stretch and it's I'm
gonna make these two episodes I don't
remember the name of the horse I'm gonna
use the ones my dream was always that he
would do my race right I've always
dreamed that because that voice and uh
I'm gonna do the one that did happen
it was I wasn't I'm smoking my dream I
I get pumped up
I get motivated and I get emotional
my dream was
my dream was to hook the feet pink eye
at a stretch
any Jackie out there knows it that's
like a
what are you crazy he was considered the
strongest
finisher of all time and feedback
there's no horse face in finishing is
when Europe on that horse and you you
just you reach up and you grab them it's
made and you pull his head up and you
push it back down you're helping him run
the feet oh remember I told you the guy
was a specimen he got a miniature
weightlifting jockey kid you not
yeah that was my dream because
I consider myself one of the best
finishers in my mind you have to you
have to believe in yourself
hey he's just a man like me
I consider myself pretty good too let's
get it on let's see what we got just
like I said when I was playing
basketball yeah you're you're very good
but I want to be that good and I
consider myself good you know I might
not be six nine I'm 5'3 but I walk 6-4
that's the way I like to say it you know
because in my mind I'm just as good as
you are even if you're even if you're a
yeah six nine six four
I got a picture it was in the Glendale
News Press
I'm holding the ball like this the ball
as big as me almost it's funny and the
guy guarded me was from Pasadena Coop's
on the other side on the court Garden
out of the guy and this guy's six I
think he was six four
I guess that's where I came up with six
four
that didn't bother me but anyway
um
I've dreamed of hooking the feet pink
eye but in the in in my in my my dream
my goal was to beat him everybody went
to you know you want to hook him but you
want to beat him too because so what you
hooked the feet and he beat you that's
not you know hooking it we mean when you
say hooking in horse racing is your your
nose to nose from the get-go
and I wanted it to just be him and I
just him and I just the whole world
watching us
that I you know what motivated me so
we're at Hollywood Park and I'm smoking
I haven't forgotten about the Harry
Hansen part
and uh the fee was I think are back in
time
and that was my dream everything's
coming together God's good to me
I've just you know I'm blessed
so I'm smoking
and I look over and there's the feet and
we're we're we're hooked we're nose to
nose and everybody else was like
kitchenette eight links back maybe more
it was my dream come true it was just
him and I
the world's our stage
now and I looked at the feet because
people don't realize when uh when you're
on a on a horse you can have a
conversation just like you and I are
because the the noise is behind you
you literally have a conversation don't
get me wrong we don't sit there and tell
you what you have for dinner things like
that it's about you know the moment like
hey hey you know you can yell hey hey
behind you and that guy in front of you
can hear you so you know if you're
cutting him off you can help him you
know you don't want to drop somebody get
them killed so
I I was confident man
because I'm you know I'm a little Stout
on the upper body for for jockey like I
used to have to lose eight pounds of
water every day
think about this that's eight
eight 16 ounce glasses of water from
your body you're literally dehydrating
yourself of eight
16 ounce glasses of your water in your
body
I know you people out there go into
that's impossible hey I'm impossible
because I did it what did you wait when
you were racing uh when I would walk
into Joshua
well when I got out of high school I
weighed um 145 I forgot that part of the
story
well I was getting it to I was going to
get to it when we get back at it when I
was at Sanita
but uh I'm into this one here I weighed
at 145 I had to lose 25 uh what I had to
get down to like to be realistic about
riding I had to get down to me to uh 115
so that you know because of being a bug
boy you got to wait you're packing
you're attacking they call it your
saddle and your boots everything
um
109
so but you know you get a little they'll
give you a pound so like I was looking
at 110. so if I walk in at 116
you know but I'd usually walk in at 118.
because like you know I'm bigger boned
than most Jacks and um I had to lose
muscle
because I didn't handle fat you know I
mean that might happen maybe a little
tiny bit but not very much from playing
basketball you know I gotta run twice as
fast as the guy that's 6'4 because of
his legs you know his uh extension in
his stride so I was in great shape and
um
so at the minute how do you lose muscle
well you know when people die of
starvation the first thing they lose
is the body eats the fat you know for
energy then the body's an incredible
incredible incredible thing then the
reason I know this is I I died on in the
back then we didn't have Google I got I
went to the library and you know studied
about how people lose muscle you know
and it literally goes to the point of
how people die of starvation is the body
eats the fat for energy sources then it
goes to the muscle
but it doesn't attack the organ muscles
because you know your organs are a
muscle your brain's a muscle your heart
until it gets through the every the real
muscle on your body you know it tries to
save itself you know it it's in survival
mode so I said man how do you know I got
to do that the way you do that is you
you take in um 500 calories for the day
and you lose fifteen hundred to three
thousand you burn that because then it's
because the body you're using that food
you ate the energy from the calories you
took in but then it goes to the muscle
then starts deteriorating eating a
muscle
in a month I lost 25 pounds
doing that and I don't I don't recommend
anybody do that you know it's you know
Insanity I would put a 25 pound vest on
when I my
father-in-law Yogi took me he relived on
Myrtle
and uh I
Pacific and Myrtle you go straight up it
goes pacifically straight up there and
then it stops at a dead end and um
I put a 25 pound vest on it you know I
just you know I wasn't like you know
booking it I just you know little tiny
steps and because you know you got 25
pounds on you don't get stupid
but I'm using it to really make my body
work to take and you know start using
calories
then when I get to the party it actually
is turned into it this steep incline and
I did that for a month
and uh I got down to 120. I said I can
do this now then the rest that the rest
of you know I you get pumped up and
motivated because you I want this goal I
want to I want to do it
so I got down like I say to 118
and um well I was at 120. but let me let
me jump back I ain't gonna miss what I
was talking about
um
uh Santa Anita I'll get back to Harry
Hansen in the part where I was starting
to ride
I'm getting too pumped up I'm jumping to
tangents so I said
I was telling you that
people won't I don't care like I say it
doesn't bother me at least I know it
happened and that's all that matters
because the rest is history to say
I was at the rail and that Harry Hansen
was calling the race
and uh
I I don't remember is uh I don't
remember the horse's name the feet pink
eye was on
but I remember I'm gonna make one up
I'll say uh I'll say back in time
and I heard Harry Hansen go
they're turning from home it's back in
time back in time starting to draw away
it's gonna be back in time winning by 15
lengths
the feet hit that pop that I go puppy
sorry hit that horse and cheese us or he
I don't remember if it was culture of
Philly just exploded and just
took off and I was true story my word to
God
or may I never see heaven or my mother
again and I'm watching
and I'm going
what the hell
I'd never seen I never had a vision
I never knew what a vision was
but when I looked at that jockey on that
horse remember I'm up on the rail so I'm
you know really up there he's going to
run bet the only thing between me and
him that horse is the turf course that's
how close I am and I looked at that
jockey and I saw me I saw my face
I was on that horse
my word to God I saw that like it's like
I'm here looking at you today like I'm
looking at your face I saw my face there
clear as day clear as
well
that's me on that horse but I'm not
there I'm here
clear as day
and I just tears started flowing out of
my eyes
I don't know I couldn't stop him
and they just kept flowing and I go
and I just I was standing on and
seriously just keep flowing them eyes
and I turned and
it looked at my father-in-law he was
back there you know ways because they
don't come up on that close you know
they don't they're not that they won't
they're what he's worried about if he
won that race or not made some money so
I walked back to Yogi and I and I
couldn't stop the tears they just kept
flowing out I wasn't bawling like a baby
I was normal but tears were flowing fast
and he looked at me goes what's the
matter with you bow and ears
and I looked him and said you wouldn't
believe me if I told you
he goes why are you crying I go I don't
know it just won't stop
and then I looked at him and I said
Yogi
I'm gonna be top 10 here in three years
[Music]
and he said no more that's when he said
no more beer for blowing ears Jackson
and I said Yogi and the tears are still
flowing
I'm serious
I'm really serious I'm gonna be top 10
here in three years Yogi
and then they they stopped when I turned
around and walked back up there
and I thought to myself
what was that all about what just
happened
and it was a vision and from that day
forth I knew I was going to be top 10 in
Santa Anita I just had to work hard and
learn the rules of the game and God had
showed me that it was going to happen
there was no question in my mind that I
was going to be top 10 of sand leader
I already seen it no question at all so
that gave me the confidence
in the really hard willpower
determination dedication desire and
discipline
because God was already there
and so I went to um
you know the
varnerian uh I told Yogi I need somebody
to help me get in there
and uh he found Danny Danny a lawyer
and Danny said
billia I think he was a photographer too
I'll be honest with you and he said I
said hey Danny I I need to do find out
how to get into the industry
he said well Billy I got a friend that
has a
jockey School
over on Calabasas I mean over the
Grapevine I forget that where it was at
but if you go up to Grapevine and you
know the big hill it was off to the
right down in in that part so I got in
my car and drove up there and introduced
myself Jim Jim fres quit fresquez was
his name and he had you know a bunch of
horses and you know he had he had been
an exercise writer at Santa Anita so you
know he knew and uh you know what you
know how to how did you because it's an
English saddle you know it's not a
normal like you know western saddle they
call it the big you know and heavy and
stuff English saddles are lighter and
they're there's not much there's no horn
on it or anything
and so I went up to him I said uh the
main Bill winland and uh I like to learn
how to ride you know racehorses
at first you got it first you got to
learn how to gather from you know
exercise them in the mornings and stuff
you don't just go out there and get into
a race it's not that easy it's like
Indie drivers don't get in an indie race
just the next day
so
I I said but I'm I want to learn I want
to be one of the best and um he said
well you got the right attitude and so I
said um when do I start you know and so
I went up there and I was working at
Highland Laboratories
in Glendale it's not that name anymore a
pharmaceutical Corporation
doing the you know cleaning up the
equipment you know in there and stuff at
high school paid good you know because
you can move up and do the where I was
actually making hemophil for this
medicine for people get burned
and it's you know you know I graduated
with two working two jobs from high
school
the director of boys athletics and uh
and playing varsity basketball with the
B plus average
not bad for a kid from Colombia
so um you know I worked hard at
everything I do but my mom always said
no matter what you do son
be the best at it even if it's digging
ditches be the best at it be the best
dig that there is take take pride in
what you do
my mom was a very smart woman
for being second grade educated
so
every day after I got done at Highland
Laboratories
um
I worked uh you know until the four
o'clock then I
shoot up to the ranch
and get you know do the class you know
learn how to you know post and all that
I I've been riding horses when I was
five so I knew you know
things that I didn't know how to call
them I didn't know that that's what I
was doing was posting you know but
that's what it is then from then I did
you know you start yeah Galloping them a
bit you know and I see I was saying man
I know how to do all this hell bust me
this I know how to run them you know
let's just have come on this is for
people are going to know the whole how
to spell the name horse so I told him I
go you know I'm more advanced than this
you know
you know and they're doing that come on
man put me on something so he said okay
well bill this isn't for you then you
know because um this is I go yeah I know
all that you know now where do I go so
he said well now you got to go down and
send in and you know get a job exciting
horses
let's do it but I you know what I can
send you you know even even don't get me
wrong exercise horses are usually you
know ex jockeys you know and all that
you're getting on some really nice
horses you know these are athletes
some of them are worth a lot of men like
you know millions of dollars you can get
killed out there two in the morning you
know this is you know you can't just go
out there and let the horse run around
run away with you these people have to
do exercise right in the morning they're
talented they really are
they get on horses that they're going to
run in a race and they the trainers
he's depending on you to tell them when
the horse is hurt and where he's hurt
and um you know these depend on you to
go easy with them in the morning so you
gotta you gotta full
force of athletic ability underneath you
1500 pound animal that can do what it
wants when it wants anytime at once
whether you're up there or not if he
wants to run and go jump over that fence
if you don't know what you're doing he's
going to run over there and jump over
that fence that rail
it's it's really heavy it's a it's a
it's an art seriously
so
he um knew a guy in Golden Gate San
Francisco
so
he says Billy let me send you up here
and that I'll tell him what's going on
and that's where I usually send people
that advance to Big jockeys you're the
first one I'm sending
you know I've never had Invaders
advances you well like I said I've been
writing as a kid bareback and so
went up there send me to a place a barn
of the Golden Gate Fields racetrack the
gentleman's name was uh Bud Keane
and uh but he was a he was a good guy
he got me you know you learned from a
bottom up you start smoking stalls
that's it so I'm looking stalls and
rubbing the horse's legs and learning
all the you know from the bottom up
then finally you know he got me got
actually Galloping exercising horses I
moved on to working horses
and then um
I was ready
he said um now I'm going to say it was
you know a process now I'm sending you
every it's funny every time they sent me
somewhere it was North it gets colder
and colder as you get North I hate the
cold
so he sent me to Portland Meadows
to his uh his uh his dad's uh his dad
was a trainer up there at Portland
Meadows and it's a it's a real small
track it's uh
it's it's you know what they I don't
like to call it like that but it's a
bush track whatever not not a bush track
don't I mean that it's um you know the
track where you know they have jocks you
know that but it's not it's not even
close to San Diego you know
so
but you guys start somewhere
and so and that was where Bud Keane
but uh Pappy King bud's dad had horses
so I got up there bud told him his kids
ready he's gonna be all right he's you
know he's got he knows what's happening
so
I'm up there and um it's cold as hell
and a matter of fact
he put me on a horse and he said okay
son this is your first one I go all
right let's do this bib's bunker was his
name
and um
I thought you know let's just do this
man so got out there I run second got
beat a nose first time out
so I thought that was that was a rush
man you know because I was actually
competing with jockeys you know I'm a
jockey now
feeling pretty good so then um you know
Pappy was going around he was telling
people hey you know this kid's good you
know put him on something man so this
other guy put me on a horse I don't
remember that horse's name I run second
again
so then um
this is the first one
this guy he put me on a horse called the
chin Chopper
and uh he goes son
just bust him out of the gate he was a
he was a front runner and he you know
but he would you know he died near the
end and um if I could get him to relax
you know we'd make it
so I'll never forget it it was night
racing night racing at Portland Meadows
is not the prettiest thing when there's
snow on the side of the track the track
was frozen and they dig it up right
it's cold and and it's like 11 30 at
night or something like that
so I'm in The Paddock and this guy goes
the owner he goes
I'll never forget that you go son you
got to win this race I go yeah well
that's my job sir no I mean I bet the
mortgage this time and you know you've
heard that saying I bet the mortgage he
literally bet the mortgage he took I
think it was twenty five hundred dollars
for the mortgage and he literally bet it
on the horse to win and I said I thought
he was kidding right hey but you know
it's your money you know
I hope he's kidding so I got on a horse
and uh we're going to the gate and the
fog's coming in
and I said
God you love me don't you
perfect because when we bust out I'm
going to lead they don't know where I'm
at oh seriously when I say fog it's
thick you know and it you couldn't see
through it and so I'd think you know
this is a beautiful
All I'm gonna do is I'm gonna bust out
and I'm gonna keep him four off the rail
because then he doesn't know see a horse
when you when you're working a horse in
the morning you get him on going and you
drop them into the rail and they take
off because that's when they know it's
time to get going right so I'm gonna
keep them off the road he's gonna cruise
around there and they're not going to be
able to see me so there's nobody on that
boom baby we bust out and I just I could
see that was the Railside moved them off
the rail there and so we just chilling
chilling they don't know where I'm at I
know I could see the rail so I know just
keep making the left there so
then we're still going it's still foggy
then I hit the 3 8 pole that's beginning
of the turn and it's starting to clear
out
so then I I hit the quarter pole and I
let's go baby let's hit it because
there's you know I can see daylight
again I reach up and grab this button
boom he just took off because he's been
doing nothing the whole time he didn't
burn himself out I went by 10 links
and as I'm going by only he only ran a
quarter mile so as I'm going by the guy
was on the track the guy that bet the
mortgage and I go what's he doing and
he's he's not not literally on the track
but he's on the edge where they take the
photo and he's kind of getting excited
and he's boom Falls right on his face
because it's Frozen and and I go he's
okay so we came back and his face is
little bloody and stuff and uh but hey
he saves his house in his marriage
probably
so that was my first win so I gotta win
and uh then I I don't recall that you
know this is 40 years ago I don't recall
the name of the second horse
I guess that one important because I
already won that one but uh
I got a ticket leaving Golden Gate in my
poor [ __ ] to go to to go to Portland
speeding ticket because I was so excited
to get there now I can't wait to get the
hell out of there so I I win two races I
went to run two seconds I go I got to go
because as an apprentice you can only
win as soon as you win five your your
time starts you got a year or or
uh a hundred wins I think it is
whatever comes first then your
Apprentice ends and your apprenticeships
when you want to really kick some major
butt because you know you're getting it
five five pound allowance off the horse
so people ride you especially if you got
some game you're really right because
you're getting five pounds off everybody
else is carrying 120 you're carrying
115.
so I get in the Porsche and it's
remember it was foggy so it's still
foggy because that night when I got done
that was like you know time to get the
hell out of there so
uh not the same night that I went with
chin Chopper because I've had I won one
more later but the night that uh I won
the second one I said I'm out of here
all I had there was my clothes you know
that I had on my back and my attack my
equipment
so I get my Porsche I take off and I'm
happy as a pig and you know what and
um I'm going along I'm you know you know
I'm gonna cruising it could move it
could move and um
I look in my left mirror and I see a car
coming up on me fast and I didn't think
nothing of it I'm cruising up I know I'm
doing 90 easy 95.
and then I look and I said oh man I see
the lights going
I got a ticket leaving and I got a
ticket leaving again
hey I like to go fast what can I tell
you on horse especially so I go officer
okay how could you tag me if if you
can't see me oh I can see your
headlights then I seen you cutting
you're moving pretty good so you gave me
so anyway that that that's the end of
that one so then I now now I got to go
to Sanita
and start you know letting you know I
gotta go sell myself
one thing I've always been good at is
selling myself
because I have confidence to have God
it's got my back and I've worked hard
and I know what I'm doing and let's do
this
so I walk into San Diego and I had the
win my first win on chin Chopper the
photo you know I got to sell myself I
gotta also prove myself you know I gotta
show my actually telling the truth a
little bit so I remember I'll never
forget I walked up that
first one first guy I walked up to a a
gentleman his name was Hal King I loved
him he was a good man
and uh
he was a Jewish man and he had a he had
a members only jacket on gray hair
he's walking behind this horse and I I
knew he was a trainer because I asked
somebody hey you know is that a train
over there he goes yeah so I walked up
to him and said how you doing he's
walking you know he's his horse is more
important than me right now you know
he's got to train his horse I understand
so I waited for him to get divorced on
the track and he's up on the rail and
he's letting the horse gallop away and
uh that was what's that son what do you
got and I go um you know introduce
myself on Bill women and uh you know I
want to be I want to ride horses here
and I just uh left Portland Meadows and
I I went two races two seconds
I only rode four horses and I showed him
picture chin Chopper all proud and
everything you know because I looked
pretty good on it you know there's still
style there he he goes son
I know I said to him he goes look I look
good right and he goes son every winter
looks good I'll never forget that that
he's right everyone everybody loves a
winner and nobody ever nobody ever
remembers who runs second or third
so
he says I go but you know I need to get
in here Mr King you know I need to I
obviously I know how to Calif horses Mr
King it's like you know can win race he
goes all right son
you saw me be here tomorrow morning 5 30
5 o'clock
I'm happy as Pig and you know what
and uh showed up and
started getting galloping horses hey you
gotta start at the bomb again you're at
Santa Anita you know what I'm saying you
just suddenly walk in there and he's
gonna put you on a horse to you know go
out there and ride against the best in
the world everybody there in the top
tens in the Hall of Fame
hello that tells you something so
I galloped horses for Mr King um
let's see for for a year
and uh well in that year um uh I would
run into Shoemaker in the morning and uh
I was selling myself to Shoemaker like
you know I want to be your friend I want
to learn you know and they all everybody
all the You Know Jack said they knew me
for by the guy that works for Hal King
because I gave Michael Castaneda a horse
I said gotta get on this horse
mercassinated great great great great
writer he was also from Columbia bota
yeah we came from the same city same
country so him and I had a little blood
you know both countrymen so I I told him
I'd go get on this horse man his name
was John Lee and Harold
because I worked him out of the gate
in the morning and all the jobs were in
there right and I'm in the one hole I
busted him out and he made a left turn
oh I got him and I was you know straight
come on everybody's already ahead of me
remember they got like a kid you're not
16th of the mile almost ahead of me a
head start and I pulled him around I you
know hit him in the ass here and boy he
just took off and I'm pulling on this
guy and I go what the hell am I sitting
on because we hit the quota pole and I'm
nose to nose with the Front Runners out
of the gate and they looked at me and go
who that because they saw me make the
left turn
they've thought who the hell are you on
because they know they had a head start
on me I have to get them straight on
and I'm leaving from a dead run now I'm
in a dead walk you know
and uh geez who are you lying like who
I'm not telling it and I did everything
I could to keep him from like I don't
know how we were rolling he would have
broke a world record on that uh three
quarters of a mile kid you not I go back
to Mr King and he goes what happened
Billy I go wow you wouldn't believe me
if I told you
I go how much how much you're running
this horse for Mr King he goes 25 000
allowance I go well I'm going to tell
you straight up but friends and I work
for you I'm gonna get four people to put
a a claim in for this horse
because this horse is a freak
we bolted left leaving the gate I had to
straighten him up get him going again Mr
King goes wow so he puts him in an
allowance made an allowance
wins for fun I put Marco on him I didn't
put him on him I told Marco go get your
agent go tell him so right there I got a
little bond with Marco Castaneda because
he knows that I know my horses
Shoemaker did the same thing with I said
shoot you got to get on this affiliate
her name is Khan she's in a maiden
allowance Mr King would ask me now when
I would work him out of the gate what do
you think you know and I go I tell the
truth you know she's a runner
God gave me a gift where I could you
know I'm an athlete I'm not an athlete I
could tell who the athletes are that's
why I looked at it you know to me it was
a simple thing you know either they got
it or they don't but when you're on
their back it's a lot easier to to find
feel and know well like I say I was born
to be a jockey so I had that Talent so
Shoemaker guide on her she went by 20.
an allowance made an allowance so now
sure knows I know horses this is good
because I get to a story where
it's that's the one I was going to tell
you in the car you'll know what I'm
talking about now remember I said Rebels
I got levels so
now now
um
it's time for me to you know Mr King to
bust me loose I remember I was Laz
Barrera was walking with them they were
really good friends lots of prayers all
the same trainer
and he trained affirmed is that does
that help you out
Triple Crown winner with Steve Kopp and
16 years old
and I never forget I saw those those
films of him and I that's where I knew I
I wanted to be one of the best of the
best
and so on
I heard him say that uh because you know
I I thought I'm I'm good
but I you know I don't know if I'm that
good because I ain't been out there yet
no I know I got it but
this gave me that that um sense of uh
confidence even more
because you can't remember I'm going in
there against the Hall of Fame
these boys been writing for 30 40 years
and they no joke
they're going to school you good either
for you or against you so I heard him
talking to those prayers I was on a
horse ago working him in the morning
they were walking behind me and I heard
Los Barrera say the kid any good
and I I heard how King go
he'll be one of the he'll be one of the
chosen
and then they said wow that's a deep
statement but it came from a man
you know nobody was talking about not so
much about Talent with me but
he'd been around a while he knew he'd
seen him come and go so it gave me that
little bit of a get get hungry get tough
let's go to battle let's do this you're
one of the best you are so
now you really believe it you have to
you have to go in there confident know
that
you ain't got nothing on me bro let's do
this every one of them the feet doesn't
matter because it you really got to
psychologically build yourself up you're
walking into it I called it when I got
interviewed for the hell Examiner
you're walking into a showroom and
you're a Volkswagen and you're walking
into
Rolls-Royce showroom these are the rolls
royces of jockeys literally
there's no Volkswagens in here bro
except you so
um
we were Del Mar and he puts me on a
horse
greets and Duchess
every trainer that has a kid that's
coming out they're going to be one you
know right at San Diego or whatever you
know any track
they want him to win that first one
to help his confidence because you know
he needs it and to show the other good
people there that you know the kid can
ride you know give him a shot you know
what I mean so you put him on a horse
it's one to nine if uh if Lafitte was on
the horse he'd be one to nine she she'd
be one tonight
so nobody knows who the hell I am the
public
I'm on the horse and I'm eight to five
so that tells you that this it's a given
we're giving the kid a winner okay
everybody just relax you know let the
kid win one right off the bat you know
it's just a done deal
you think so
I'm in the one hole she's got all the
speed in the race she
loves the front end she's gonna bust out
and she's gonna go to the front and I
just gotta sit on and relax and she'll
win like she's only one in the race like
it was working a horse in the morning
my luck
there they go
she walks out breaks dead last
you don't like no dirt in her face oh
these horses say I just sat there and I
remember what Shoemaker told me
in the Josh room
about Del Mar he said Son
he called me bug
he's the only one I ever let call me bug
bug's a bug boy you know because I'm the
little guy I want respect you know
Shoemaker call me
[ __ ] if you wanted to that's
Shoemaker that's the man to me and the
feet but that's the only one that would
allowed to call me but when Jack in
there called me bug one day I said only
true has that Pride that that privilege
I mean he can call me Buck you call me
bug again I'm gonna kick your you know
what okay
Case Closed nobody ever called me bug
except you so it we leave the gate
I'm sitting on her I said he said bug
when they when they hit the turn from
they all always drift out because
they're asking them to run already so
the momentum carries them out I go okay
so I remembered all of a sudden they
were too taught but what he told me so
I'm on the rail and you know she's
making up ground but on her own you know
she's just getting there she it's like
she's running her own race they're not
there so that's how I'm writing her I'm
letting her run her race
she's just doing it all on her own we're
at the corner pole and that opened up
like the Red Sea and I haven't asked her
to run and I'm up there there's only
like three like two links in front of me
the Front Runners you know like at just
the beginning of the term for him and I
said we got this baby yeah kick it she
shoots through that hole you know like
you know it wasn't like it was about
from here to here she shoots through
there and I just the whole way it was on
the rail
she goes and draws Way by five I look
like like I've been riding for 20 years
because the kid didn't Panic you know
and everybody in the world that bet on
that horse was cussing me out when she
broke dead last I guarantee you that
including Hal King he bet two thousand
win on her and I didn't know that at the
time I didn't you know I don't care what
you bet but man I felt so good man I
said Thank You Lord that I look like
like biggest hero in the world on horse
racing I know it
so because I knew everybody would say
this piece that [ __ ] kid he can't ride
for another game he know how to break a
horse out of the gate even you know and
I know they were saying it so then I
come back to Mr King and he said don't
you ever F and do that to me ever again
and they smiles and Winks at me because
he knew
that was meant to be because that made
me look real good any kid can get out of
the gate go to the front and sit on it
no I showed them I had Poise confidence
and just relax and let the horse run its
own race you know
and I said I went back at him I go I
know I look good as hell didn't he so I
get off the horse and took a shower and
I'm walking back to go see Mr King in
the in his box well we got the racetrack
and I uh walking up there I got like 20
guys asking me hey can I be your agent
can be I said man it was like a like a a
Muhammad Ali just just won his first
bout and they saw you know how bad he
was you know boom boom boom like a
butterfly sting like a bee you know and
I felt you know I felt like
photographers were shooting my picture
and stuff at the Academy Awards and I
and I just smiled and it was like I
couldn't hear anybody it was just like
my dream came true you know I I'm gonna
make this happen you know this is
happening that Vision I saw that day is
coming to be it's coming to be
and I didn't know what to say and I was
just an odd and I just had I just I had
to get the hell King because I you know
I now I'm getting it's come becoming a
little overwhelming you know and I just
wanted to stay on the ground so um don't
let your head float away you know just
stay calm and stay uh humble so I went
to Mr King goes okay that was very good
son and I and I said now I'm all pumped
up can I can we give me an agent can we
give me an agent you know because you
know I want to do this
be patient be patient and
next thing you know I'm uh
you know because we were living in a my
girl my my girl and I live we're living
in a studio on Brand Boulevard here in
Glendale and you know she's roughing it
with me and um
I I said um
you know she's all pumped up anything I
said no we got to calm down I got to get
a good Agent you know Gotta Have a good
agent and uh
she was getting all depressed and stuff
and then I started thinking well
man she's been roughing it with me for a
long time so I went and I said Miss King
I need I need to start writing you know
it's been a long long road and I need to
you know move up a little bit in life
you know my woman and stuff because Mr
King knew Loretta and he loved her and
he said well son and so I that was a big
mistake I made and I I regret it but you
know it was it was it was something I
felt I had to do which you know he told
me wait for it I'll get you a good Agent
I got this one I don't mention no names
but uh it was like I didn't have an
agent I wasn't writing for no big barns
none
and um
I didn't know this was going on but the
big barns didn't like the guy I had
and I thought he'd be all right because
he was with the the agents that Mr King
wanted me to get he was good friends
with them so I thought I'd you know I
wasn't that stupid I thought he was in
with them they'd be I'd be all right
big mistake
and so I didn't find this out till I was
done riding my apprenticeship though
that none of the big barns liked my
agent if I'd have known that I'd have
fired him the first day you know what I
mean and God only knows where I would
have gone
because as with no agent I was in the
top ten at San Anita I was I was it had
in front for the eclipse award as an
apprentice of the year with no agent no
big barns
but that's hindsight I didn't know I
didn't even know I was in front for the
eclipse award because you know it's not
by winds it's by money earned Sanita if
you win One race they got to win 12 15
20 to catch that money you know I ride
one there it's a 50 000 purse those are
five thousand so he puts me on the
course uh at San Anita reticent lady
this is called coming to that that
Vision so I'm in a gate no no yeah
mitigate
and uh I look over there and they all
know me I go okay guys let's get it on
literally you know I'm one of them now
let's do this let's rock they bust that
gate open at three quarters a mile I
bust her out and get her on the phone
lead come on down the rail and I'm
cruising cruising cruising remember
Harry Hansen so and I'm just getting a
turn for home and I hear Harry Hansen go
ladies on the front and I reached up and
I got her and I because I was just a
little bit off the rail you know and I
started riding her and she just took off
and I'm riding her and I hear her answer
go down the stretch they come it's
reticent lady reticent lady drawn away
by 15. remember that Vision that was
right there same thing that I saw that
day that the feet was on her 75 000
people yelling and it was just me out
and 15 in front division happened that
was the one first win at San Anita and
so it wasn't it wasn't my imagination it
really happened and it happened then
so now we start moving on now I'm pumped
up I'm in the top ten we're at Harwood
Park
I'm in a horse name I'm smoking this is
what I was telling the car
and that Shoemaker in the feet and Dr
curling
they would bet the pick six
and I'm sitting there and I'm getting
dressed putting my boots on and uh
I'm listening to him and I go yay shoe
this is takes balls
you get who you got in the that race
that you're talking about I mean me and
the fever eight to five ninety five you
don't have me
no you better put me in you ain't gonna
win the pick six
30 to 1 shot hadn't run in a year
what tuck takes balls he looked at me
like yeah okay the feet but to me like
is this kid drunk 30-1 hasn't run in
here
I said it's true you know me I know
horses you better put me in there
curling goes who is this kid you know
and she looked at me and I said you know
me
he goes put him in
30 to one shot beside the Gayton I win
by five
I didn't say nothing
true story I didn't say nothing that
took some balls didn't it to tell them
that I'm gonna win the race you're
telling the two best that ever lived
there you're going to beat them in that
race and you're 30-1
you better win this when I'm thinking of
this I knew I'd Win It
I knew something about that he had a bad
shoulder they fixed it and I worked them
in the morning monster monster went
three in a row with him so that's why I
earned lafitte's respect all right so
now this is the one I was telling you
about
um that's what I was telling took balls
this one this is one about being the
feet hooking it at the pole at the quota
pool so I looked at the feet that day
and I said okay the feet you looked at
me he has that Pan American accent
I go
let's get it on baby let's do this he
goes okay so we're we're just him and I
the whole world is watching
and it's like a match face actually and
we're on the rail and I just challenged
the best pound-for-pound finishing
jockey that ever lived to match down the
stretch
and he said okay let me teach you a
little bit Punk right so he puts me over
to the we're already on the grill he put
he pinned me on the rail this is how
good he is knowing that you're tight but
you're not in danger the hell I wasn't
my boots rubbing the rail literally I
got white paint on my boot I didn't know
what that I had that but I knew I'm
rubbing the rail and but see he didn't
know what he did was phenomenal
phenomenal race riding that's a race
writer right remember this jockeys in
those face writers he pinned me I
couldn't hit right-handed he's there
couldn't hit left-handed rails there the
thing he didn't know was it when I'm
smoking got hooked you don't need to hit
him he pins those ears back and he's
telling you he's doing what I'm doing
you ain't beating me that's not going to
happen today he's digging in his ears
are pin so I know he's giving me
everything he's got the feet don't know
he don't like to get hit with a stick
when he gets hooked you do he stops he
said he'll back you off so
I never knew it but he said see the wire
there's no wire there see the wire it's
almost like grasshopper
you're one of us see the wire
after a while I saw the wire there is a
wire there people can't see it you got
to be chosen
and I'm coming to a wire I know where
it's at I see it I know it sounds crazy
but it's I can't explain that one so
we're getting there we're getting there
and I see the wire Wham right on his
nose right on the right on the wire his
nose goes up and mine's down
and I knew I had him I knew I got him
end up Galloping out and the feet looks
Amigos
they win
you get my words in the face
no the feet I didn't mean to the hell I
didn't hear me rubbing the damn rail
look at my boot you wanted to get it on
you gee we got it on oh man I earned his
respect that day
we got in the Jock's room it was on a
Sunday no it was on a Saturday and uh it
didn't begin oh sorry I get too into it
the whole Jackson I'm gonna go take a
shower I didn't get to get off and start
you don't shoot your mouth you just get
off and you know you won that's it let's
show some class don't start talking
trash never
got to be classy you're with the best
act like one of them so I'm going to the
shower all the jocks are in there I'm
walking by and you know I've got my
towel around me my robe hey when
yes
he never talked to nobody he's always
within himself unless you know your
friend like chew into them
what are you doing Sunday night my heart
dropped
all the Ducks are listening what the
hell
nothing let's see I don't care if I was
getting married that day I was that what
is it you what do you want to tell me
tell me because you're obviously tell me
you want to do something with me and I
would be honored so he goes I'd like you
to have dinner with me and my wife ah
but this is the kicker
he didn't say it that uh the SmokeHouse
restaurant and
I said we're at a feet like you know
where's the restaurant at my house boom
that is that is
I I would give up winning the Triple
Crown my word of God
to have dinner with the legend like that
in his own house with his wife come on
that's priceless that's a true story I
mean I had that and uh he showed me his
house I was magnificent and he's and I
said wow the feet he lives up here in
Las Vegas four million dollar house in
1981. and he I go you know I mean it was
I don't want to get into it how his
house was but it's phenomenal and I go
wow he goes don't worry you'll have all
this you'll have all this don't worry
and uh
basically
um
that um that that was one of the most
incredible things I had the best job
best agent in the world remember I told
you I'd give it up
from New York
hey Mr winland you know Joshua you got a
call I go to the house from New York who
the hell it's called me from New York
I'm going to be in New York I don't know
it's a guy so I go
it was top page in the country
he wanted my book he has all the big
barns in New York he's telling me and
I'll make you lead an apprentice leading
jockey in the nation because you've been
watching you know
they watch our races we watch theirs but
I I'm that high on myself you know I
don't know what people are saying but
they were talking evidently big time you
know it was up and coming next Legend
whatever
and uh I didn't know this but this is
how much being in that atmosphere and
being with them meant to me I said no
I'm fine thank you
yep I could have been leaned I was
already leading Apprentice with no agent
you know what would happen if I would
have said yes
we'll never know is that your biggest
regret yeah yeah
and that's basically that's that's my
career in NHL how many years did you
race uh I raced uh 10. then I had a bad
accident
and uh
yeah it's the biggest regulator but but
but
what I had there that was priceless I
was good all shoemakers parties birthday
parties I was I was I was a maid jock
you know and if Bob Felix said I'm a
made man I was a maid jock kid from
Columbia
who the hell is this in Colombia Bogota
remember my father was an alcohol I
could never remember his name my mom
would tell me but my subconscious
wouldn't let me hold it
because it broke my heart two years old
he my mom we got rescued by my Father
John Woodland because he was always
threatening to kill us true story this
is the end of the story
my mom took my two sisters from my
stepfather to Colombia when they were
older to learn Spanish
they go to the movies this is this is
how the world is Destiny in the universe
they go to a theater who's there
The Man Who let that we that was going
to kill my real father my mom was goes
up and says hello and uh you know what
are you doing here he was there by
himself in Colombia Botha I was a hero
you know you know an athlete hero like
and uh
I didn't know that and Mark lucasinated
too at the theaters during intermission
they would show our races
he was there watching my races
kicking himself in the ass going
that's my son he'd tell people my mom
said he tell him that's my son that's my
son
yeah the one you walked out on you know
and I think it was too much for him
because uh two years later he did it he
killed his new wife and killed himself
yeah really I mean so say yeah and you
know what I I don't I never hated him
but
you know you do what you do in life
you make your bed you sleep in it you
know he couldn't take it he couldn't
take the fact that that was my kid and
you know what was I think you know hey
you don't have to kill yourself that's
what happened that's true story yeah
Billy what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
don't ever give up
yeah
my mom
because
I'm sorry but it just happened take your
time
ah
you know I just lost it what three weeks
ago
um
because no matter what
you want to do in life
you can do it
even if you only have a second grade
education
you can raise four kids
and you can raise them to be gentlemen
you can raise them to be
strong
and you could be their father and their
mother too
every lesson I've learned in life
came from my mother
she lived to be 90.
and I thank God for those 90 years well
you know the years that I was in her in
the in my life here with her
and um
I'm proud to say that she was my mother
it's a great story
no it's you know it's like I say she
lived a good life and it's just
you you hate to say goodbye
that's the toughest thing in life to do
I remember the first time I saw death
was when I was on that farm I was in
charge of the dogs
and uh
Brown wouldn't get up and I told my
uncle
Paul
Brown won't get up I've been talking to
him and pushing him and everything I
didn't know death I didn't know what
death was he just wants to keep sleeping
I can't get him up
he goes son
he's gone no he's not he's right there
no he's gone to heaven no he's not he's
right there
no son he's dead
well what's dead he 'll you'll see
you're gonna die one day too like oh
that ruined my life you know what I'm
saying thanks I thought we lived I did I
thought we lived forever you know and
that's why I learned about death and I
learned that everything has its time you
know and it was his time and so it was
my mom's time
and she wanted to go it's just that I'm
selfish I didn't want her to go right
and every kid's office about his parents
leaving and uh I remember she told me
that this true story now ended she was
on the operating table and she died my
mom was going to lie to me she said she
was above the operating table watching
them and she's seen a light and she went
towards the light and
the angel said no Lee here called her by
name it's not your time you got to go
back my mom was pissed like you would
never believe most people would say
I don't want to die and she's just
running to that light I bet you she
wanted to go be with my father you know
with John winland all these years when
he died he died of cancer when I was 13.
he was you know they were separate
though because he was the war ruined him
alcohol and all that you know and um but
I think every day that he was my father
he if I hadn't been on that farm
he put me on my first shelving Pony Buck
me off my Father John Willen and I had
cried he said get back up on that horsey
little [ __ ] and I'll never forget that
I was only this tall I'd come up to his
knee and if he hadn't put me back on
that pony
this would never have happened you know
and I know it and if he hadn't found my
mom see everything we're all destined to
go where we're going you know if we
don't know where we're going till we get
there if she had met him I wouldn't be
here either you know what I'm saying and
uh but she loved him so much but she
left after a while came brought us here
you know and uh she he was dying of
cancer and she flew his two daughters
you know from blood back there and I I
talked to him and it's that bad and I
said Daddy
I was 13. I was here in California and I
said I I'd be honored to have your name
I promise you my first son would be
named after you and uh he passed two
days later he said son you've always had
my name and so I went to court had the
paperwork done and everything and I got
it you know I still have it and uh my
son my first baby was a boy and uh I
named him after him John Charles women
his name is John Charles Chon Chon was
Loretta's grandfather
and uh women so I came my promise you
know but yeah that yeah that was that my
mom was probably the toughest thing that
she was something else man four eleven
that she walked six four
I did something wrong she's coming to
get you with a extension cord a broom
whatever she could get her hands on
you're at it they either run out the
door because she was good she'd get you
in the ass as you're running out she was
a tiger she was a go-getter I guess
that's why I am too and I I never she
was only four eleven but I never said
damn why couldn't I took after my father
like my brother because he's like five
ten or so
hey look what I got with it you know and
all the women are taller than me I would
walk around with I dated like some women
that were like five ten five eleven
they like me they like me right you know
and put heels on you know now they're
like six one or something you know I'd
walk into a party and they'd say how the
hell what do you do Bill get these away
I go hey you're all the same size when
you're laying down what the hell
all right buddy okay thank you so much
for sharing your story yeah that's it
that was great thank you for having me